When you first install an operating
system, you have the bare minimums of a
computing platform. To really enhance
the capabilities of your system, you'll
probably want to install some
applications. And these days, you can
find applications on a dedicated app
store or you can download them directly
from a website and install them in your
operating system. But of course, not
every system can run every application.
We have to make sure that we're using
the correct operating system, perhaps
even the right version of the operating
system. We have to make sure we have
enough memory, storage space, and other
resources. And there are a number of
considerations that are important to
keep in mind when you're planning to
install an
application. First, let's talk about the
operating system capabilities itself. We
often put operating systems into one of
two categories. either a 32-bit
operating system or a 64-bit operating
system. And usually this determination
is based on the processor type that
you're using on the system. A legacy
system might be running a 32-bit
operating system, but most of our modern
computing systems are going to be 64-bit
systems. And as you've already seen,
Windows 11 only provides a 64-bit
version of the operating system. There
is no 32-bit version of Windows 11.
There are a number of reasons for this
move from a 32-bit operating system to a
64-bit operating system, but one of the
most compelling reasons is its ability
to store and retrieve information from
memory. Your operating system uses these
memory addresses to know where to store
information and then where to retrieve
that information. And with a 32-bit
operating system, you can store
approximately 2 to the 32nd power of
individual address spaces. This means
that there are about 4 billion values
available to choose from. If you're
looking at a 64-bit operating system,
those operating systems can store 2 to
the 64th power of values. That is about
18 quintilion values. This means a
32-bit operating system can reference
approximately 4 GB of memory space, but
a 64-bit operating system can reference
approximately 17 billion gigabytes of
memory space. It would be very unusual,
if not impossible, to find a computer
these days that could store 17 billion
GB of memory on its motherboard. But
certain operating systems can certainly
support large amounts of memory space
with the 64-bit OS. You need to check
the documentation of your operating
system to determine what the maximum is
for that OS.
Not only is there a difference in
operating systems between a 32-bit
operating system and a 64-bit operating
system, there's also differences on the
type of software you would install on
those systems. For example, if you're
installing a hardware driver, that
hardware driver needs to be specific to
the OS version. So, if you're installing
this on a 32-bit operating system, the
hardware driver also has to be a 32-bit
hardware driver. The same thing applies
for 64-bit. If you're running a 64-bit
OS, you need 64-bit hardware drivers. If
you're not sure what type of operating
system you're using, you can always go
to the about page inside of Windows.
That's under system about. And inside
that view, you can find that it will
tell you how much memory is configured
on this system, what type of processor
you're running, and it will tell you the
system type. In this particular example,
it is a 64-bit operating system using an
x64-based processor.
64-bit operating systems are also more
flexible than 32-bit. For example, a
32-bit operating system cannot run
64-bit applications. However, a 64-bit
operating system can run both 64-bit
applications and 32-bit applications.
So, if you are transitioning from a
32-bit OS to a 64-bit OS, you may still
be able to run your older 32-bit
applications. Windows tends to store
these different applications in
different folders. If you look under
your program files directory in Windows,
you'll see that 32-bit apps are stored
under program files x86 and 64-bit apps
are simply stored under program
files. There can also be large
differences between the video
capabilities on one system to another.
Many systems have the graphics
capability built into their existing
central processing unit or CPU. So your
CPU and your graphical processing unit
are on the same physical chip on that
motherboard. This allows you to save
power, save space, and you don't need
additional technology in your computer
just for graphics. We refer to this
combination of a CPU and a GPU as
integrated graphics. But there may be
times when you need to use more advanced
graphics capabilities. You might be
doing 3D modeling or you might be doing
some type of video editing. In those
situations, it might be worthwhile to
have a dedicated graphics card like the
one you see here. This is a discrete
graphics card, and it's usually
installed separately inside of your
desktop computer. So, when you're
planning to install a new application,
make sure you check the graphics
requirements and see if the built-in
integrated graphics will work or if
you'll need some type of external
dedicated graphics card.
One important resource you'll need when
running these new applications is how
much memory will be required. Most
applications will provide you with a
hardware requirements list for the
application and it will tell you how
much memory you need to have free in
that system to be able to use this
particular app. This is a relatively
important resource because if you don't
have enough memory, this application is
either going to perform very poorly or
not at all. So, make sure that you have
plenty of memory available to be able to
run the application that you plan to
install. Also, keep in mind that the
requirements for the application are
just for the app itself, not the
operating system and not any of the
other programs that you're running
simultaneously. It's often good to check
Task Manager to see how much free space
is currently available in your system.
And if you find that it's getting close
to the maximum, you may need a memory
upgrade to be able to run that
application.
Some applications require a CPU with
plenty of processing power. So there may
be requirements on the speed of the CPU
that you're using. This is usually a
measurement on the processor itself that
is measured in gigahertz or GHz. One
hertz is equal to one cycle per second.
So
350 GHz would be the same as 3 1/2
billion cycles per second. This speed
value is a broad measurement. As we've
already seen, some CPUs have additional
capabilities that go beyond how fast
that CPU happens to be. For example, we
described integrated graphics and how
the integrated graphics and the CPU are
all on the same chip. But if you're
trying to determine the minimum speed
that you'll need from a CPU to be able
to run a certain application, this
becomes a good value that you can use
along with the other resource values
required for that app. And as you look
into the details of these applications,
you'll find that these measurements for
CPU speed will vary quite a bit. For
example, for word processing, you may
find that there is a very minimum
requirement for CPU speed. But if you're
planning to install an application for
video editing, it may require a CPU that
has much more processing
power. There are many different ways to
license applications. For example, if
you've installed a Windows application
or operating system, it may have asked
you for a license key to be able to
unlock that particular app. With
higherend applications, you might see
that this is not a license key that you
would type in, but it is a physical
hardware token that must be connected to
that computer. This ties the application
to this physical hardware token plugged
into a USB interface. When you launch
the application, it looks for this USB
hardware token. And if that token is not
connected to your computer, the
application simply won't run. We tend to
see this type of licensing with
applications that tend to be relatively
niche and have a very high cost per
seat. This allows the application
developer to ensure that only people who
have paid for this software can rightly
use it because they're the ones that
have the physical hardware
token. When you install an application,
it often asks where you would like to
store this information. Some
applications are relatively small and
some applications take up a lot of
storage space. So you'll need to look at
the requirements for that application
and you'll need to check how much free
space you have on your storage drives.
You may find that most of the time
applications have plenty of space to be
able to install themselves and run
properly on a system, but there might be
specialized applications that use very
large databases or store large amounts
of data. And in those situations, you
may want to pay close attention to the
requirements from the application
developer to make sure that you have
enough storage space on your system to
install and use this
app. Over the years, we've started to
move away from physical distribution of
applications and simply provide those
applications as a downloadable product
over the internet. This makes it very
easy to install from a centralized app
store or directly from the product
manufacturer's website. When you are
installing an application, you are
putting someone else's code on your
computer. So, there is a level of trust
that you need to have with the program
that you're installing. For that reason,
we recommend not installing applications
from a third party, but instead
installing those apps directly from the
software developer. In the past, we used
physical media to install our
applications. So, we use things like
optical media like CDROMs or DVD ROMs.
And most recently, we've used USB
drives. And if you don't have
connectivity to the internet from your
computer, you may still need some
physical media just so you can plug in a
USB drive and install that application.
And there may be times when your
computer does not have direct access to
the internet. For example, in a data
center, you may find that certain
machines do not communicate directly to
the internet. So, in those situations,
you may need to install the application
setup files on a separate piece of media
like a USB drive and then use that USB
drive as your installation source. Often
the installation for an application is a
single executable file that runs through
an installation program. But you may
find more complex software like
operating systems are distributed in a
different format known as an ISO file.
This is a disk image that contains all
of the files separated into different
directories into its own file system
inside of this ISO image. The actual
file system on this ISO file is an ISO
9660 file system. And the term ISO file
is based on the standard that was
created by the International
Organization for Standardization. And if
you were to mount an ISO file in your
operating system, it doesn't simply
display a file name with an ISO
extension. It instead opens up the image
to show you all of the files and folders
containing within that single ISO file.
We've also taken this idea of images and
applied it towards an entire storage
drive. So we can create an image of one
operating system and then use that image
to create additional clones of that
operating system in our environment.
This makes it very quick to be able to
deploy multiple systems because we've
created a single base image that
contains the operating system, all of
the necessary patches, all of the
applications required by the company,
and any specific configurations for your
network. When you then install that
image on a separate system, you've now
created an exact duplicate of that
original system. One challenge you have
with images is that the image itself has
been configured for particular type of
hardware. And if you install this image
on a system with identical hardware, it
will work seamlessly. But if you install
that image onto a system that has very
different hardware, you may not have the
hardware drivers required to make that
system work properly. One scenario where
the hardware is identical every time is
a virtual machine. So using an image to
be able to easily deploy a VM makes for
a very quick installation process with
very little configuration required. This
is the way that most companies will
deploy new systems or replace a system
that happens to become damaged, lost, or
infected with malware. They'll simply
remove the computer, put a new one in
place, apply the image, and minutes
later you're up and running on a brand
new system.
On your home computer, you may install
new applications all the time. And
whenever you have a problem with an
application, you simply uninstall it and
continue working normally on your home
computer. But in a business, we have to
be very careful about what applications
we're installing and what impact it
would have by installing that app. Keep
in mind that an application that's being
installed has exactly the same rights
and permissions as the user who's
currently logged in. So any files on the
local system, any shares that are
created on the network or any access to
any other resources on the network are
also available to the application that
you're installing. This also means that
an untested application could
potentially cause problems and it could
affect any of those resources that the
user has access to. You may have even
run into situations where you've
installed a new application or you've
upgraded an existing application and
then suddenly the application is no
longer working. Or perhaps the
application used to run very
efficiently, but now you're noticing
that the application tends to lag and
slow down. or once you've installed the
application, you've noticed that some of
the previous documents you were working
on are no longer available on that
system because they were overwritten
during the installation process. This is
one of the reasons that most companies
will test applications in a test lab or
in a sandbox before deploying those
applications into production. Of course,
all of our systems are connected to the
network, so any application we install
will also have access to all of those
internal services across the network. We
also have to keep in mind that these
applications are accessing data files
that may be on a user's local computer
or those data files may be over the
network. That means the rights and
permissions for those file shares
becomes important because we don't want
the application accidentally deleting
data that it should not have access
to. Most of the time, an application
upgrade tends to be very similar to the
previous version. There's not a lot of
differences between the older version
and the most recent version. But I think
we've all seen situations where we've
upgraded an application and the user
interface has a number of very different
changes inside of it. When you're
deploying to a single computer at home,
that might not be a huge issue. But when
you're deploying this application to
hundreds or even thousands of people
across an enterprise, one single change
to the application can have a dramatic
effect on the efficiency of the company.
There's usually a workflow and a process
in place for most organizations. And
when the application changes, it may
also require a change to that workflow.
That change may take time to document
and make sure it's working the way you
would expect. And that's another reason
why testing these applications before
deployment can be so important to an
organization. And of course, sometimes
installing an application or upgrading
an existing application causes your
entire system to fail. There are of
course many documented cases where an
upgrade to an application or an
operating system causes the entire
system to fail. So you need to be very
careful about how you perform these
applications and what the recovery
process would be if you run into a
problem. These types of problems can
create significant financial issues for
an organization, which is yet another
good reason to test all of these
applications before deployment.